I'm John thanks all for coming on so
what's your reaction to this story that
an ally of Christine Ford's according to
Leland Kaiser apparently tried to get
Kaiser to change her sworn testimony
which is she deserted I think we'd both
agree is a crime it's certainly wrong
what do you make of that well I don't
know that I agree it's a crime and it is
something that we've seen on both sides
and we know that Cavanaugh you know was
also talking to his friend she was
talking to hers so you know I think what
it all boiled up before you Peppadew I
mean I think I've followed it pretty
closely is there an allegation that
someone was pushed to change sworn
testimony there was talk about Cavanaugh
talking with his friends who might be
approached by the FBI and the way that
your character I was like they have
sworn testimony was not actually no way
that story wasn't in the wall she's
saying that she was pushed to change her
personal section she was asked to
revisit her account I'm not gonna defend
that that's for me to defend because I
don't actually think that it's the right
thing to do but both sides are getting
what I actually do think the right thing
to do would have no such it would be
pretty one to take a breath and take a
step back and actually take the time to
go in and investigate all this stuff
both on behalf of the accused and the
accuser so there could be some clarity
brought to this and the right heap so
let me ask you Noble so when you start
missing in this process because there
was a rush to get it done it would have
been nice of you yeah there's only 7 FBI
investigations into cab I do think we
would need an eighth FBI investigation -
you know what the charges that don't
make it has also had clearance and no
one knew he was a child molester for a
long long time so let me be clear what
we're not going to do is try to impugn
Brett Cavanaugh's reputation by
comparing him to a child molester
because that would be wrong and guilt by
association but nothing to do with Denny
Hastert as you know but let me ask you
this when you see your senator from the
Democratic Party Joe Manchin of West
Virginia announced his vote which is
consistent with what his voters want
according to the public opinion polling
and a bunch of angry left-wing children
surround him and scream at him does that
bother you at all is that the kind of
democratic process that
you want for your country I mean people
do have the opportunity to approach
their elected officials and and make
their voices and scream at Joe Manchin
defend the First Amendment in a way that
the left is not so I will take a back
seat to no one on the first medal
question I they have a right to do it I
guess but is that what you want do you
want people screaming at lawmakers until
they change their view and if that's
okay why is it not okay to slash their
tires all right cocktail to the front on
C I'm serious if you're gonna bully
people what's the kind of limit to that
well and you've got bullying on both
sides we know the both oh you really so
show me the mob screaming right-wing
children that's changed to vote I think
it's a waste of time to go after and
scream it mansion and do all of that
he's voted the way I expected he would
vote the entire time which it I think is
viewed by him as the politically safe
way to go I have to say I'm actually
really at rest
I'm really impressed with senators
Collins Murkowski and Heitkamp because
it was very clear that all three of them
put some serious thought into this I
still expected Collins to vote the way
that we expect her to vote tomorrow on
the on the confirmation but it was clear
that she actually put some thought into
it I don't agree with everything she
said but it was clear she she made a
reasonable case and now she's being
dismissed as some right-wing crazy the
same you know the same sort of
thoughtfulness can be applied to Kowski
and Heitkamp as well Republican a
Democrat role yeah well good luck to
them good luck to them John thank you
very much for coming on a number